لو وفرت قيمه كوب قهوه اليوم كوب قهوه كوب
واحد لاصبحت غنيا تخيل او على الاقل
استطعت توفير شوي شوي عادل
استطعت توفير تكاليف سفرك بحسب
بدلا من انفاق هذا المبلغ يعني يقولوا
ثلاث دولارات ويعتمد على حسب نوع القهوه
ثلاث دولارات ثلاث دولارات دولارات ونصف
تقريبا ثمان فنجان كوب القهوه كل يوم اذا
قمت بتوفيره فانك ستجمع ما يقدر بانمي
وسته الاف دولار بعد ثلاثين عاما
طبعا اذا نظرنا بطريقه مماثله لمشترياتنا
اليوميه الاخرى لربما استطعنا ايضا توفير
مدخرات محتمله في الملياردير مثلا قدر انه
كان يمكن ان يدخر 300,000 دولار على
امتداد حياته عن طريق ضبط جدول حلاقه شعر
بس هو مش مضطر الحلاقه شعر طيب هذا النوع
من خطه الادخار التدريجيه تحتاج الى تغيير
نظرتنا الى انفاقاتنا اليوميه او نفاقنا
اليومي وحساب كم يساوي مقدار المشتريات
العاديه بمرور الوقت واجراء تخفيضات بسيطه
في الانفاق طبعا بحسب المؤلف ديفيد باخ
حتى تصبح ثريا لا تحتاج الى اكثر من
الالتزام بخطه مدخرات واستثمارات منهجيه
[موسيقى]
قسم الاقتصاد من هناك اتينا بالزميله سمر
الماشطه حتى تقول لنا هذه الوصفه السحريه
صباح
[ضحك]
الخير
قالت تصير مليونير ما عرفت احط الكود
وطالع خلينا نقول له مليونير بس تكاليف
السفر الى وجهات معينه هذا الصيف وخلينا
نكون اقرب الى الواقع فمثلا عندك من ارخص
الوجهات اللي موجوده اليوم اذا انا سويت
شويه بسيط اذا افترضنا طبعا كوب القهوه في
منطقه الخليج اكثر من ثلاثه تقريبا خمس
دولارات بالمتوسط اذا افترضنا انت كل ما
رحت على الاوفيس على الشغل تشتغل 22 يوم
مثلا بالبيت لما تكون بالبيت حتسويها
بالبيت اشتريت القهوه الجاهزه من احد
المحل بدون ذكر اسماء حيكون عندك 110
دولارات كل شهر يعني اذا ردت تروح متوسط
تكلفه اجازه لمده خمسه ايام بدون التكت في
تبليسه اللي هو هوايه من الخليج اليوم
يروح عليها في عاصمه جورجيا تكلف 250
دولار فعندك اذا 250 دولار فعندك تقريبا
شهرين من
القهوه من كوب القهوه شهرين حتدفع تكاليف
خمسه ايام اقامه في تبليسي
شكرا جزيلا لك
المشطه زميلتنا قسم الاقتصاد شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات